what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to polo g heating up
featuring young
oiv before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos just a
reminder my instagram is where i accept
video requests it's just dot pearly
things and while you're at it if you
have watched three or more of my videos
please consider subscribing
we have beef if you don't to be honest
because i do this out of the kindness of
my heart
yeah and i feel like if you've watched
three of them you should subscribe okay
um i'm also going to try to pause this
every
20 seconds so i don't get copyright
struck
[Music]
what's the worst he folks i been
stacking running nothing rockies in the
trenches with my wait so i'd be stacking
so he's talking about money okay
gold
and the trenches that's like
not a good area basically like i'm in
the trenches not a great not a great
place to live you could say i live in
the trenches now because i live in the
hood in london right now [ __ ] [ __ ]
up we dumped the district i ain't
signing no no deal unless they talking
about some figures put that bag on top
your head and have your partner call me
kill you i know sometimes i'll be turnt
up they claim they left wait have your
partner come and kill you
do you mean like your girlfriend
come and kill you
oh no
if that if you if that's the situation
you're on you need to find a new woman
i'm just saying
my homie
[Music]
okay so he's saying he used to be down
bad right but now he's got a couple
racks and he's showing his success in
the music video through his chains you
see that he's like i
am successful and i will let all of you
know it
so here's my chain i used to be down bad
now i'm up and i have cash
which should be put in a bank account by
the way i don't know why we're just
like that's asking to get robbed that's
like saying hey come rob me i feel the
same way about chains to be honest
i lost them all and got them back they
gripped my homies cause the other shot
was working with the fence when i got
caught up for them things they said it
didn't go around the edge i be tripping
off the things i popped the eggs get on
my back i don't like
[Music]
did he make a gun noise did someone get
shot
something blue
like
one that's an interesting lyric i i
don't polo g
i don't know what you're thinking with
this lyric choices there's a lot of ways
you could say the same thing um also why
are you just falling
you're just like randomly okay
[Music]
pull up and let off a couple shots from
out this time so once to that restaurant
these [ __ ]
he's not faster than his met
what did that say hold on
you pull up on him
faster than his i heard matt
i don't get it
[Music]
okay so he's saying that the cops say
he's destroying the city
um guys that's not a good thing
um if you get a message like directly
from the police telling you that it's
time to make some new life choices
because if you're causing chaos for
everyone around you
that's very selfish it's not a nice
thing to do
okay dangerous they've been blocked just
for the hell of it we gonna keep on
laughing [ __ ] that's how you let that
pressure hit all my homie like it's
shooting dice and shooting at the bricks
ever since my little brothers died he
always kept a stick how do they have
this many friends that said i never
understand in these videos like
that's at least let's go back hold up
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten like at least 12 people
i guess famous people have a lot of
people friends but
i remember hustling and robbing trying
to catch you late i was out there [ __ ]
been that feel like colin kaepernick all
the snipers they don't give a [ __ ] my
nail whack a [ __ ] i just sent the addie
to her dm now my machole splatter [ __ ]
okay so he said i just sent the dm
to or the addie to her dm so what are
you saying it see he's inviting a nice
lady i'm assuming to come over and like
hang out
um they call it a booty call
nowadays i'm not i'm not gonna tell you
what to call it but
she's i guess that's how you do it in
2022. pop out cuts and let that helmet
spit you with my ass you can't touch
there's no empty hammer [ __ ] always buy
my loan some more i'm linking up with my
savages think twice before you run up
all my guns get to clapping [ __ ] sun
down to the sun up pick a gun up who you
ran with wait
sundown tell the sun up pick a gun up
one that's clever rhyming i'm gonna give
you that one
but
if you're you're dealing with guns sun
up to sunday my siblings they hunt
but if you're doing that all day sir
i i think you need to get a hobby i'm
not going to tell you what to do
but you could get like guitar lessons or
something wait you would think the block
of barbershop the way we line the [ __ ]
can't wait for the summer oh that was
clever
you would think the glock a barber shop
the way we lined this [ __ ] i don't think
i'd like the meaning cause the glock's a
gun
i don't know what lining a gut but i'm
sure there's a double meaning i think it
was clever watching drums we got all
kinds of [ __ ] while a [ __ ] he don't got
it all he gets esparza quick
[Music]
okay um
i hate to say it guys i hate to i hate
to be the one to say it okay
it was okay i'm not um
i got like a two out of five you know i
do one to five skills here like a two
um i i will say the guys looked pretty
cool
in the video like
cooler than i love her look don't get me
wrong i will never look that cool um
but
we don't
is that the message we want to we want
to spread about guns and stuff i don't
know let me know in the comments though
don't forget to subscribe i'll talk to
you guys next time